buenos dias raúl desde cali este
miércoles de paro nacional va a servir
para medir la temperatura de las
protestas si éstas empiezan a decrecer o
si por el contrario se reactivan a pesar
de como comentabas de la visita de iván
duque del presidente iván duque a cali
para destacar que todavía quedan
demandas de los manifestantes como una
condena del gobierno a la respuesta
policial también la retirada de reformas
como el proyecto de salud y así como un
ingreso garantizado para la población
por lo que el anuncio de iván duque de
la gratuidad de la educación superior
para estratos de uno y dos y tres en la
universidad pública a partir del próximo
semestre o la investigación de 65 casos
de posible abuso policial no parece que
vayan a terminar de contentar a los
manifestantes en cali este miércoles
además va a ver diferentes los puntos de
resistencia de bloqueo que habido en la
ciudad de cali que han estado dominando
desde el pasado 28 de abril cuando
empezó el paro nacional van a volver a
hacer convocatorias y concentraciones y
también se va a realizar a las 2 de la
tarde en puerto resistencia un plantón
en el
a ver una performance que se va a
repetir en otras ciudades de colombia y
del mundo para homenajear a las víctimas
por lo que como te comentaba raúl este
miércoles va a ser importante para ver
hacia dónde avanzan las marchas aquí en
cali en los próximos días
así es guys también le pregunto por un
punto importante en estas marchas y son
los indígenas que ha pasado con la
marcha indígena que se encuentra en la
ciudad de calle
así es esta va a ser una cuestión
importante puesto que la minga abandona
a cali y esto despierta dudas entre la
gente si va a hacer que los
manifestantes pierdan el ánimo y vayan a
abandonar los bloqueos o si por el
contrario también puede hacer que ellos
mantengan la primera línea y se aumente
la respuesta policial ya que la minga
había sido una contenedora
de enfrentamientos la minga asegura que
abandona a cali por seguridad propia
recordemos que el domingo hubo un ataque
de civiles armados contra la minga que
dejaron al menos ocho heridos y la minga
también ha asegurado que van a continuar
con el paro nacional en sus territorios
puesto que de los cinco mil que hay en
cali la mayoría provienen del cauca la
región del cauca la minga también ha
dicho que rechaza las negociaciones que
está llevando a cabo el comité de paro
con el gobierno y en este caso van a
abandonar la ciudad de cali para
continuar con sus protestas en la región
como comentábamos así es gracias por
toda esa información por supuesto muy
pendientes de lo que ocurra hoy una
ciudad de cali muy buen día